2020 2021 and 2022 have all been weird
years but today I want to share with you
a few things to look out for for 2023.
[Music]
by the way if you get value from this
video out then give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel number one I
call this your it's a word the year of
Investigations you're going to see 2023
being a lot about investigations what
kind of Investigations sand Bank been
freed from FTX Hunter Biden since
Republicans got the house now Trump's
going to be more investigation going
it's going to be investigation after
investigation after investigation until
eventually politically both sides are
going to be like hey man can we just
stop all of this investigation because
it's all retaliation right now but I
don't think it's going to stop this year
it's going to be one of those weird
years you're going to hear a lot of
Hunter Biden a lot of trump a lot of SPF
and I think a lot of other people that
are going to be investigated this year
because that's one way of bullying and
re avenging your enemy and there's a lot
of that going on in 2023. get you
sustained a following two things are
going to matter made in America but also
made in India a lot of people are
gradually going to go away from China
realizing how much they control
manufacturing all this other stuff
that's sold you hear companies like
apple well you know we're still going to
do a little bit of our stuff in China
but they're moving to India you're going
to hear a lot of Microsoft other
organizations going to India so the
value you're going to see a lot of that
stuff come from made in China to Made in
India and more companies are going to
brag about the fact that our clothes are
made in America our phone is made in
America our this is made in America that
transition will be taking place which
means India is going to be going
vertical and economically if they do it
right and keep investing into education
that economy is going to be growing the
next year two years three years four
years five years next one China is going
to have a rough year because it's just
going to be challenging for them no
matter what they're talking about
they're not making a lot of good
decisions they're starting to get people
from both sides from political aisles
from the left and right now challenging
their positions they're trying to play
aggressive hey stay out of the way but
there's some protesting this is not
usual for China for this to be taking
place the people are starting to get
sick of the amount of controlling that
they're having that this is not a good
look for them so it's going to be a
rough year for China in 2023. I think
it's fair to say last 12 months I've
been very scary for the average investor
whether it's inflation interest rates
gas prices home equity value all this
stuff that's taking place I mean some of
the numbers the average investor this
year lost roughly 44 the 60 40 portfolio
that's been used for many many years is
down 34 it's worse in nearly 100 years
as a result there's been a lot of
investments into Alternatives by some of
the biggest players in finance
institutions allocating 30 to 50 of
their assets to Alternatives retail
investors are following suit McKinsey
project the retail share has potential
to more than double the next three years
so what alternatives are they looking
into Goldman names Fine Arts as a way to
help protect purchasing power it has a
correlation of less than 0.3 to any
other major asset and even Morgan
Stanley reports the average piece of
Fine Art is selling for 26 percent more
at auction compared to this time last
year so the company Masterworks allows
you to buy into these multi-million
dollar pieces of art but buying fraction
kind of like buying a stock into Apple
you're buying a stock into the same
multi-million dollar art they qualify
each offering with the SEC which you can
find at the Edgar Edgar database.cc.gov
over 600 000 users over 650 million
dollars in art so in other words let's
just say they sell a painting that you
invested in whatever the return is you
get a piece of that return that brings
them to 7x is this you're ranging from 9
to 36 percent net internal rate of
return and that's a real number by the
way but remember Masterworks deals in
over a half a billion dollars of
physical art from Legends like Picasso
Bank seat but not nfts we've also linked
to Masterworks SCC offerings circulars
in the description and they can also be
found at scc.gov however the thing
obviously there's a lot of interest for
what they're doing people are interested
in this and there's a long waiting list
however due to valuetainment if you go
through the vitamin link you can skip
the waiting list process I'm going to
put the link below click on the link if
this is something you want to consider
investing in for the next six 12 months
as an alternative investment I highly
recommend you go learn more about
Masterworks Point number three goes into
Point number 4 do not be surprised if in
2023 Point Tick Tock gets banned in the
U.S the way it was banned in India and
couple other countries don't let that
surprise you Americans from both sides
again are not trusting Tick Tock this is
going to be a big pain for a lot of
people that build their brand purely
around tick tock they're going to have
to adjust to go to Instagram or Facebook
or Twitter obviously this is a bigger
opportunity for Twitter but you're gonna
see something happening with Tick Tock
it can happen like this and by the way
if it doesn't happen in 2023 it's most
likely going to happen in 2024. interest
rates are not going to slow down anytime
soon although they may in Q2 or Q3 my
prediction because if Jerome Powell
decides to all of a sudden go up a point
to just kind of shake everything up and
see inflation drop and then to go back
to half a basis point increases or
quarter of a basis point increase gonna
keep doing that but that interest rate
is not going to be slowing down anytime
soon so Q2 Q3 which all that means is
real estate is about to take a hit it
already has in 2022 but it's going to
get worse than ugly in 2023 That season
is coming and it's going to be
challenging for a lot of people in the
real estate industry the real estate
people are saying the following I think
this is going to be a flat year what
they're trying to say is the Market's
going to go down if experts in the real
estate industry are saying it's going to
be a flat year just take 20 and drop it
minimum that's what's going to happen my
opinion I may be wrong again in 2023.
all that means is they're finally going
to say we are in a recession so get used
to the word recession actually being
said by the government the reason why
they say that is because 2023 is the
year where you're really going to see
the amount of ugly things that was going
on in 2022 that was hidden or kind of
manipulated because of midterms you're
going to actually see that stuff raw in
2023 which means you may actually hear
our president say we are in a recession
and use words as soft Landing a lot in
2023 but a recession will be here very
soon High likely at 70 plus chance
recession is going to be here in 2023.
next one I was having dinner with David
Solomon the CEO of Goldman Sachs last
week in Miami and I asked him a question
and I said hey David I know every year
we have a different number that comes up
some years we talk about interest rates
inflation you know crypto this this that
no one's talking about unemployment rate
because right now it's a 3.3 3.2 3.5
percent where are you guys with what's
going to happen with unemployment next
year and you heard them say well we
think it is going to be a number some of
them said 4.3 4.4 percent is where
unemployment is going to be next year in
2023 I think it could very likely be
higher than that you're hearing a lot of
different stories with companies not
only freezing firing going out they're
hurting and it's being felt everybody at
Mike table at that event with Goldman
Sachs was a small event with 30 40 of us
everybody on my table said they're
either laying off firing or only keeping
the employees that are going above and
beyond that was everyone on my table who
all run a good sized business for
themselves so from Q2 on you're gonna
hear the word unemployment numbers
unemployment numbers unemployment
numbers instead of being inflation
inflation is going to be replaced by
unemployment so you're going to see our
politicians and presidents saying even
though unemployment is high we have
never seen inflation drop the way
inflation has dropped so they're
bragging about unemployment right now
nobody wants to talk about inflation
inflation next year they're going to
brag about inflation and no one wants to
talk about unemployment you'll see that
shift taking place Q2 Q3 of next year
around Q2 Q3 people are going to start
saying I'm running for office to be a
president so get used to the campaigning
part you're going to see again numbers
for CNN and fox and MSNBC going back up
because it's the season for them Super
Bowl is around the corner for politics
in 2024 and this is when people start
saying I'm going to run I'm going to run
I'm on a run so it should be an
entertaining year with people announcing
the run for office it'll be very
interesting to see if there'll be any
wild cards I got some ideas about some
wild cards but we'll see what's going to
happen 2023 is going to be a rough year
for the Iranian government here's why
they have been imposing their power and
bullying for way too long and women
finally said we're sick of it masamini
she passed away the amount of protesting
that started a lot of people said well I
was going to slow down that became
worldwide and it was protesting all over
the world and then Iran came out and
said well let me if you if you guys
continue to do this we're going to
execute some of you and they did and
they did publicly hanging a 23 year old
Majid Resort
which they just did that a day ago and
then also at the same time there are
claims right now that they're giving
death sentence to Iran's Amir Nasir
azadani the soccer player who was
protesting for women uh uh and the whole
conversation was around the world cup
they're saying they're going to kill and
execute this man if Iran continues to do
this this strategy is not going to work
because the world if they just sit there
and watch and not do anything about I'm
talking about different regimes what
they're saying is they're indirectly
supporting this behavior and if any
country gives the Iranian government
money like especially if the U.S gives
the Iranian government money all they're
saying is we're okay with you doing what
you're doing we don't condone this so
it's okay if you're doing this part we
just don't want to get involved like
Hillary Clinton recently said we just
have to let them figure it out for
themselves really in 1978 you didn't let
that happen you had Jimmy Carter and
Kissinger come in and have Iran fall and
then when they did we saw what happened
to Iran and the rest of the world
because your involvement of manipulating
what you did in Iran so hopefully I'm
very optimistic that this will be one of
the worst years ever for the Iranian
government because I just don't believe
the people are going to take it anymore
I think it's going to be a rough year
for their government so this is one
opportunity Iran has to get democracy
back there and make it a free country
hopefully it'll happen I'm not here
saying they ought to it they're not they
shouldn't do it because I understand how
much of a risk this lies for the
families and the parents but I've not
seen the conviction of the people today
at the levels that we're seeing today
I'm not Tina like this ever at least not
in my lifetime every year there's a few
lists of names that I like to follow to
see what's going to be happening I think
this year we're going to hear a lot of
Rand Paul fauci because I don't think
they're going to be done investigating
fouchi this is not going to be a good
year for fauci fauci is going to be in
the news criticized constantly if he was
a hero in 2020 in 2021 he's going to be
a villain in 2023 exposed with a lot of
different things especially since Elon
Musk just bought Twitter and they're
talking about prosecute fauci that's not
going to be something he's just tweeting
for the hell of it it's going to be a
rough year for fauci Republicans want
the house you're going to see a lot of
that I think you're going to hear SPF
and FTX all year long investigations not
going to be slowing down anytime soon
this year it's going to be a rough year
for them the scientists he's the leading
candidate right now in Las Vegas betting
so he is officially number one in his
biting in Trump uh do not be surprised
if sometime q2q3 he announces it I think
if it's a close advisor to him they're
telling him the only way you're going to
have a bigger credibility score than you
do today is you need another Black Swan
and you need to make your decision
properly again and so do you want to
wait four more years I don't think he is
I think he'll be announcing we'll see
again outside of that anybody Elon Musk
hires uh I wouldn't be surprised if
certain people move to want to go run
with Elon Musk uh and Twitter it'll be
very interesting it's as if he's putting
everything else in pause Tesla's stock
is down uh you got some of the other
stuff that is doing uh fine but I think
that's going to be an interesting year
where people going to say I want to come
around with you I want to come around
with you I want to come and run with you
so he's gonna anybody you got Matt Tye
berry wise you got those in but there's
gonna be a lot of other names that could
potentially join with them some
potential big podcasters are going to
want to go to Twitter and run with them
don't be surprised if that was to happen
I think if there's anyone that can pull
it off it's in bye-bye grizzlam is going
to be there with Disney how he'll turn
it around with Tim Cook will they sell
to Apple a Disney sale to Apple could it
potentially happen in 2023 I think think
there's a possibility for Bob Iger to
try to restructure the reputation that
they have in the last but not least
Newsom keeps saying he's not going to be
running I think this is a very big year
for Newsome to try to get in there
because there's no way the Democrats are
going to let Biden be the leading
candidate to run left I think after
midterms don't be surprised this is
going to be a little weird prediction
that I'm making and I may be very very
wrong I don't think I am don't be
surprised if the mainstream media
fully turns on Biden to Corner him to
say the same way we cornered you know
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders Amy P to
say hey everybody get behind uh Joe
Biden to become the president I think
the same way they're going to Corner Joe
Biden to say it's time to step away and
you need to announce it and then they're
going to give him a nice Legacy stuff
but they do nap on Joe Biden to be
running again next year don't be
surprised if mainstream media fully goes
on the offensive at him CNN MSNBC
everybody Hunter Biden all of that stuff
do not be surprised if that happens in
2023 again I may be fully wrong that's
why you call them predictions it's not
meant to be 100 these are purely
speculation of what things that could
happen in 2023. if you got value from
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel I got another
video I want you to watch it's titled
how to plot your next 15 moves as an
entrepreneur if you've never watched
that click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Applause]
[Music]